you
hi everyone is Jerry this is game 2 of 4
from the match between Hikaru Nakamura
and the world's top chess engine
stockfish something I forgot to mention
in the Game one video as that stockfish
is without an openings book in each of
these four games in this game - Nakamura
is playing black again with the
assistance of an older version of Rybka
and again for the most part I'll simply
be showing the moves of game 2 with some
brief comments along the way so
stockfish opens with deform Nakamura /
rybka playing Knight f6 we see a King's
Indian in this one and I believe black
gets exactly what they wanted
out of the opening in particular a
closed position after c5 and rook to be
one that's officially what we have a
closed centre and also a very nice
Knight anchored in the white position on
d4 with rook b1 white is prepping B for
black stops this directly with Queen b6
another idea that I've seen is to simply
allow b4 and reply with the b6 to
reinforce e5 but now wanting the Queen
side to open up at all Queen b6 stops
that a3 the bishop is kicked back to d2
notice that if it's going to e3 this
Knight is all the more annoying since
you can never even think about taking
Knight takes Knight because there would
be then a recapture and a fork so
instead it's Bishop d2 a5 clamping down
on B for B 3
what is b3 doing well if b3 is not
played there can at some point be a for
a nice positional idea to clamp down on
b3 and maybe then jump into that b3
square with the knight so b3 it is
Bishop d7 watches over the a 4 square
from any Knight jumps also just
connecting the rooks Knight g3 a big
question in this game
which is a very long one lasting nearly
150 moves is where will that next pawn
break be with the center closed the main
things black has to think about is will
it be B for that white eventually plays
or F for or maybe a combination of the
two we'll see soon enough in this game
we see a great deal of shuffling back
and forth until there is a structural
change okay but first Queen c7 Queen c1
going back to b6 Queen e1 Bishop e3 and
the rook is going back and forth here
for black not a lot of progress okay
some progress here with age 3 because
it's watching over g4 which is paving
the way for f4 if you do f4 right away
there's always this Knight g4 move you
have to deal with so black going back
and forth and now a4 okay with a 4 we're
pretty much saying there's going to be
absolutely nothing happening on the
Queen side it shut down neither side
will move forward with the pawn break
and because of that the attention will
be specific to the Kings side of the
board and I was talking about the pawn
breaks that black I'm sorry white has b4
+ f4 well you can forget about b4 at
this point the only pawn break now to
consider is f4 what about on the black
side the only pawn break really do you
maybe think about is f5 but that is a
pawn break that is probably not going to
be benefiting the black side if anything
it's going to be more helpful to the
white pieces opening up this diagonal
allowing this Bishop to finally
contribute in the position instead of
staring at his own pawns ok Bishop to EE
is anticipating this pawn break in
vacating d7 for an eventual occupation
of the e5 square so as black you have to
anticipate f4 these these are the F pawn
in the epon being exchanged in that new
square e 5 would then be a perfect home
for pieces
so Queen d2 King h7 finally f4 is in
black is now quick to get to the e5
square and this is a very strong home
for the night very tough to break down
this black position again nothing
happening on the Queen side y tries to
get piling up on this square the Queen
is there in time to defend f7 this is a
threat at this point to take on e5 and
then take on f7 Queen e7 is there to
defend the night is repositioning to
challenge the knight on e5 the strong
point in the black position b6 secures
this pawn so that the rook can finally
come over and help control of the e5
square 93 f6 so very secure e5 square
Queen e1 rook on a to e8 a lot of back
and forth eventually we have the Knights
exchanged and another structural change
soon
h5 is one day maybe looking to trade
dark square Bishop something that does
happen in the game this is maybe also
directed at not even allowing the Jeep
on to advance and think about an ensuing
pawn break with g5 okay Bishop d2 rook
to f7 it is at this point we have Knight
takes Knight and with that comes now a
structural change we have D takes e and
now this is a connected past pawn
something I was looking at is well
ideally I was thinking you should be
wanting to capture with the F pawn on e5
of course in this position it's no good
you're dropping the rook but just
backing up a little bit I wonder if you
can make a different move I was
wondering if you can make a different
move such as Bishop to d7 and alph
Knight takes Knight now you could take
like this but you can because of Bishop
to g5 and if rip takes rook there's rook
takes rook and your queen is in big
trouble
so you can't capture like this in other
words after rip to f7 you're not going
to be able to capture like this if you
just do some kind of shuffling on these
squares you're still not in a position
to capture like this so is there really
ever a position where you're able to
capture with the pawn I should also note
that what about after Knight takes
Knight
let's after rook f7 Knight takes Knight
what about Queen takes Knight well
notice how this is allowing the d6 pawn
to have fire placed under it Queen the
e7 there could be queen to e3 and ideas
of putting pressure on this pawn this
pawn and even a timely pawn push and
then this Bishop gets right to life okay
this is in fact maybe even a winning
idea on the white side so my main point
here is that black needs to certainly be
in a position to capture on e5 with the
pawn is it ever possible to capture with
the F pawn on the e5 square what if
instead of rook to f7 suppose Bishop to
b7 is played so now if Knight takes
Knight you could take here and you're
not at least immediately getting killed
with Bishop to g5 but notice how there's
still progress to be made on the white
side in the following variation this
Bishop is very active the Queen is soon
to become very active by way of f2 let's
say the bishop gets back involved and
now Queen to h4 and there's already
ideas of maybe one day putting pressure
on the d6 pawn maybe even the b6 pawn
and maybe even the h5 pond coupled with
a g4 a timely g4 push they're still
going to be a ton of pressure placed on
the black position if we have a
structural change with Knight takes
Knight Knight takes Knight and F takes
Knight okay in the game however it was
rook f7 Knight takes D takes Bishop e3
Queen to d6 and we are at move 40 we
have a ton of shuffling that goes on in
this one eventually what's going to
happen is that the dark square Bishop is
get exchanged
not sure how many moves it even takes to
get there but I'll just keep cycling
through here eventually it's going to be
a Bishop h6 move and the dark square
Bishop scum off and then another series
of nothing type of moves nothing has
changed for as long as the structure
stays the same he's of course immune
from capture because of the pin on the F
file so as soon as this Queen is no
longer in c1 I believe that's when we
have Bishop h6 hopefully we get to that
soon notice when the dark square bishop
is what we will see eventually is when
the dark square bishop SAR off the board
we see something quite curious that
maybe we wouldn't have seen with well
many years ago with computers in
particular a king walk okay so finally
the queen is off this diagonal the dark
square bishop SAR off and like I was
just saying there's a king walk that
happens in this game white is eventually
going to get the king all the way over
here and then look to open up the Kings
side of the board and exposed the black
King but just like we already saw
there's yet again more shuffling looking
at move 90 and going forward black of
course has to be in a position to watch
over h5 with the rook on g3 this pawn is
pinned so more shuffling happens
eventually white will make progress not
with any pawn advances but rather with
the king so eventually he's going to
take a hike any moment now hopefully
soon okay we have h for one other pawn
advance this was a bit of a surprising
move the h5 move quite sure why was
played I wonder if there were moments
where maybe black could have played h4
and because of that move there wouldn't
have been a great structural change that
white could maybe look forward to
getting in by having this pawn on h4 the
only pawn break that you have to watch
out for is g4 and well eventually that
happens in this game but of course not
while this King is still on the King
side
he's going to start to run and finally
took about 108 moves before he got
rolling here
there's nothing unfortunately that black
can do again trying to open up the
position I don't know that you could
really do that the button the white
pieces are in a perfect spot it won't
expose your King so easily so finally we
have a pawn break Queen to d6 and Queen
to c3 we have f5 so this is now another
critical point in the game as it turns
out it becomes very awkward for black
after this f5 move and the King is very
vulnerable so I had wondered looking
back is there a way to still just keep
the pawn structure as is what if you
don't play f5 suppose there's something
else like I don't know just going back
and forth with the bishop if you don't
make this structural change maybe white
is still going to be able to make
progress in the following way let's say
rook f3 rook here just this
back-and-forth stuff and now we have a
pawn break with g4 and this is
benefiting the white side H takes bishop
takes if Bishop takes rook takes this
King is getting more and more vulnerable
because now there's an additional pawn
break an additional pawn as well to put
pressure on so the sitting and waiting
game probably won't do black any better
so black is trying something with f5
breaking himself it takes rook takes
rook is now very active like it's out of
the pin we eventually have the bishops
coming off but who has
the safer king so of course the white
side all major pieces on the board just
a queen and rook on the board passed
pawn however and now with h5 this is
very difficult that's too difficult to
see what the exact variation is why this
is so good the computer when I was
looking at it at this point it was
struggling to you know wasn't over like
a plus one advantage it took a while
before it realized any great advantage
here on the white side I'm currently
looking at it in it it's showing at
moved twenty-two depth only at about a
point nine it's slightly starting to
increase however notice the diagonal
that has been opened after takes like
this we have a diagonal like the b12 h7
diagonal and even the g7 square that
could be more accessible to the white
side and we do see that but to great
effect soon enough we're going to have
the white pieces stacked on the G file
okay so that this pawn gets set into
motion black has to do something about
that of course so he's a bit of a
distraction to the black pieces when the
black pieces try to stop him from
advancing the white pieces do something
else directly against this now very
vulnerable black king so after e5 we
have pressure against h5 rook backs up
the Queen backs up that's very curious
proof Queen a4 I have no idea of the
specifics of these moves at this point
just far too difficult rook to d1 Queen
f4 this pawn gets rolling throwing a
punch at the black Queen a couple times
Queen to f1 Queen to g2 mate threat on
g7 rook takes pawn Queen g5 threatening
all sorts of stuff to take just as an
example take checks here you're winning
the rook
is happening soon so there's just too
much too many made threats in fact at
this point you're already having to give
up your queen rip to h1 rook d6 takes
Queen takes is needed Queen takes and
this is not going to be hold about on
the black side there is no fortress
available you might think oh if I can
just keep my rook on d6 defend my pawn
control the D file this King can never
come over in this direction that's not
exactly the case eventually the Queen
maneuvers herself to a central post and
once she's on d5 King F for King to be -
it's at this point that Nakamura resigns
and for a good reason this King is going
to simply approach and once he's in a
good enough position White's already at
a point where you could sack the Queen
for the rook and then have a fast track
to eating up these ponds and that'll of
course be a one King and pawn in game as
a quick example if ruk g6 there is king
to see one or two basically any move at
this point getting the King rolling King
here the rook could just go back and
forth if at any moment this pawn is
unprotected they'll eventually be some
fork of the King and pawn and he'll be
lost and once he's lost these guys will
go down soon enough so you could give a
check like this King g5 well well here's
one variation you can just give a check
if the King moves just grab the rook
again that's the main idea get the King
to d3 at some point you'll be able to
land some fork and then just go in this
direction it's going to be a win but as
it was in this game after Nakamura saw
King to be - and he's going to be
advancing in this direction it's at this
point after move 146 in a very long game
I'm not sure how many hours but it was a
few hours at least this one took it's at
this point that Nakamura / ripka
resigned so that's all for this video
feel free to check out
at the end of this video an annotation
link to game 3 where we had something a
little bit different Nakamura was
playing as white without the use of the
computer and he was playing against
stock fish where stock fish did not have
an H pawn to start the game so that's
all for now take care bye c5 I'm not
quite sure what we're supposed to call
this I guess we could still say it's a
Sicilian
tonight f6 Knight c3 knight c6 d4 okay
an open position just like it Sicilian